all right let's get right into your
emails for the week if you want to send
something in comment question trolling
critique whatever
um use the email address info
davidpackman.com or click on the contact
button at davidpackman.com either way
it'll all go to the same place let's go
through and see what is on the minds of
the people that is ultimately what
matters I heard from Kay
who says hi David it's been interesting
seeing how many
um for lack of a better word crazies we
have living us among living among us in
the US and Australia the only thing I
want out of this when things finally
settle is an agreement from the right
that if you can argue that no one can
tell you what to do with your body then
at a minimum we should all agree that no
one can tell a pregnant person whether
or not they can carry they carry a
pregnancy to term I don't agree that a
fetus is a person but if we ignore that
position
no one can argue against abortion that
you're taking a life because your
failure to take a vaccine or wear a mask
puts the rest of us fully viable and
already living people at risk but I
suspect consistency is something
right-wingers aren't really Bound by
keep up the good work uh appreciated you
having guest hosts rather than no show
helps that I already follow Jesse and
Farren yeah I mean listen Kate without
saying this hat this is the only way to
present the hypocrisy the hypocrisy we
are seeing from the anti-choice right
um with the my body my choice stuff
during the pandemic it is an incredible
hypocrisy and I I want to remind people
of something I've been saying for a long
time
um they're stated principles are not
sincerely held in many cases it's just
the talking point
that they believe gets them to the
political outcome they want most readily
and when the talking point no longer
works or doesn't apply all of a sudden
then they abandon it completely they are
transparently dishonest in that way
let's continue next message is from Matt
this is just horrifying Matt Rhoden hi
David my mom is a medical doctor in
North Dakota
she told me today that she had a patient
who claims that a different medical
provider a nurse told them that the
covid-19 vaccine causes an increase in
quote non-food cravings for things like
cigarettes alcohol Etc and literally in
the nurse's notes for that patient that
my mom was reading the nurse wrote down
exactly that she advised the patient
against the vaccine because the patient
was trying to quit smoking obviously
this is more anti-vaxx BS but neither my
mom nor I had heard of this before or
heard of this one before so I figured it
might be interesting to let you know
thanks Matt yeah you know it there's a
sort of like the calls are coming from
inside the house type of nuttery going
on and to hear that there are medical
providers that are opting against
getting vaccinated where it's allowed
that's extraordinarily distressing and
disturbing and then to hear something
like you know I don't think the vaccine
is right for you because you want to
quit smoking and the vaccine will make
you crave cigarettes so that's a new
reason that they've come up with not to
get vaccinated horrifying stuff and as
crazy as any of these things sound to
you or me remember that there are people
for whom this sounds reasonable and that
is maybe the most horrifying part of it
all email from Angie
Angie wrote to me Mr packman of course
spelling my last name wrong very common
that people who write in to suggest
conspiracy videos don't spell my name
correctly Mr packman take a look at this
YouTube video I believe that you will
see things differently this is a video
from Dr Christina Parks that's been
floating around I don't even know if Dr
Parks is a medical doctor
um you know the this is another
hypocrisy with the right they love to
play Coy with how does Jill Biden get to
be called Dr Biden if her doctorate is
in education
um and then all of a sudden they have
people commenting on vaccines like that
person last week we highlighted who has
a PHD in like organizational systems
commenting about FDA approval process
anyway the Christina Parks video has
been floating around
um it is not credible it's been debunked
it is
um not something I would be paying
attention to let's just put it there and
I did see the video it does it does make
it makes me see things differently in
that I'm realizing there are people who
are even more gullible than I previously
believe that's what I learned from
watching this video and reading the
comments next email is from Deanna
Deanna wrote can you do a segment of how
many people got coveted at Obama's
birthday how many had coveted at the
party and made it a super spreader just
thought that it would be great for those
people to know the answer people are
asking me hey what about Obama as far as
I know
the Obama birthday was not a super
spreader event
uh I however don't think there's
anything special about Barack Obama I
said I went to a birthday party a couple
weeks ago 12 people went vaccination was
required and a test at the door was
required my friend got tests and
everybody was tested on the way in it
felt safe it felt responsible when I
asked Dr racanello about it last week he
said you know even if someone was
incubating you probably have 24 hours of
not being contagious assuming you got a
negative test
um I don't know if everybody at Obama's
birthday was tested we've not heard of
it as a super spreader event it doesn't
mean there might not have been cringy
videos released that that's a totally
different story but I don't believe the
rules should be different for Democrats
or Republicans if you've been watching
this show long enough you would you
would certainly know that okay let's go
next to Michael's email
this I find this one interesting Michael
wrote to me about the voicemail segment
and Michael said David I would first
like to say I enjoy the show I find your
temperament soothing on my drive home
from work you're funnier than people
give you credit for but if you let that
go to your head you will ruin it Choose
Wisely to the point sir I noticed you
seem to have stopped finding the humor
in these ludicrous voicemails you play
you look drained while they play if you
don't enjoy it don't do it got to take
care of yourself first sir either way
love the content be well no I mean I
sort of play up the truth is Michael
this is actually this is actually sadder
I'm kind of so desensitized by the
completely out of this world wacky stuff
that comes into the voicemail line line
in the email line
that I really don't have nearly the
reaction to it that I should like I
should be depressed I should be drained
by the voicemails and emails that I'm
getting from people
but for some reason I'm not and I think
it's that I've become desensitized so I
think I just kind of play up you know
when I'm listening to those voicemails
um but it's not about uh enjoying it or
not enjoying it or whatever the case may
be but let me tell you Michael I really
do appreciate the concern that is a
really important thing I I love that
you're concerned about me but all is
fine if at some point I don't want to
play the voicemails it's the simplest
thing no more voicemails and I will make
the decision
um because ultimately I am the decider
on the show okay last one here we're
including a hate mail I'm including the
full full name of this person because
it's not their real name they write to
me under a pseudonym John Smith
and this uh individual wrote to me and
said dude you're a hack Biden left 85
billion military equipment Left Behind
including night vision recognition
technology which has all Afghans who
helped American
30 uh I mean it's you know I'm reading
it with the grammar that it came in 13
additional U.S military casualties this
was the most one single event f up by
any American president in the history of
the world make that the dumbest stuffing
thing ever done by a world leader in the
history of the world that was one
sentence
continuing you support this then you're
an effing idiot you can only hide
ignorance for so long Biden already an
idiot took the worst job an idiot can
take now this idiot is on display for
the world to see I I'm having trouble
following who the idiots are what a
proud day for capital L liberals maybe
85 billion was worth getting rid of
basically lib Dems Biden all members of
the squad thank you all will America
make it to the 2022 elections China Iran
and Russia are getting ready to take the
lead in world power
so there's geopolitical confusion here
Iran is not in the running here to be
world superpower at this point in time
could be in the future but not not right
now
um the question of Joe Biden leaving
Afghanistan is one to which I have an
emphatic and definitive answer
we had no business being there and I'm
thrilled that Joe Biden got us out the
ark here is George W bush got us in we
stayed for 20 years Obama didn't get us
out Trump didn't get us out Biden got us
out were there uh tactical elements that
could have been better handled yes but
there would have been tactical elements
that could have been better handled if
Trump did it as well and when Trump was
actually asked to articulate with Stuart
Varney last week on Fox Business what
exactly would have done would you have
done differently what do you make of the
specific criticisms Trump ranted about
who knows what he had no actual answer
so I am very happy that Biden got us out
85 billion is very little relative to
what's been spent uh and it is right for
us to be out it was you know the
scrutiny that is being applied to
getting out over the last last month was
never applied to 20 years in Afghanistan
so you know John Smith or whoever
um uh be mad at me if you want but uh
maybe spend a little more time on syntax
and grammar than making foreign policy
criticisms that you seem to not fully
understand all right my friend if you
have an email if you want to be featured
in the Friday emails write to info
davidpackman.com I look forward to
hearing from you but be polite be polite
guys don't be like John we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com get yourself instant
access plus when you remember you're
supporting the show and that's a
beautiful thing we'll see you then